Further restrictions can be built into a reflection model, such as maintaining
energy conservation. This means that there's not more energy reflected from the
surface than shines on it. For example, the diffuse term should drop off when
the specular term is stronger. This sort of reflection model is called
physically-based since it has some relationship to how light truly works.
Within film production and game creation there's a trend towards
physically-based systems. One advantage is that materials are more
understandable by artists. For example, with our energy balanced Blinn-Phong
material we can adjust the shininess without worrying as much that we'll also
have to adjust the overall intensity. One element in a physically-based system
is getting the materials right, but that's just to start. For example, the time
of day might change from daytime to twilight, so that the overall illumination
in the scene is considerably less. Instead of making everything dark, some
rendering systems try to adapt. This is similar to what a photographer does by
adjusting the exposure. One way is to compute a high precision image and
automatically change the brightness and contrast to make the displayed image
look good. This sort of analysis and display is called tone mapping and is
fairly commonly used in games and other applications now.